[Music]
cross-stitch for rappers are you joking
I'm an anomaly in this scene for sure
I'm Emma McKee and I'm across the
Chartist I create custom one-of-a-kind
crosses jackets for Chicago's creative
class
[Music]
cross-stitch is a antiquated form of
stitching traditionally done by your
grandma fell backwards into it
I made a present for my mom a couple
years ago so I taught myself out of
cross stitch it came very naturally to
me and so I decided to do more I felt
compelled to do it but I didn't know
what to do it for wasn't the obvious
connection was well I'll do it for the
things that inspire me and the things
that I loved were art and poetry and
music Chancellor ever is like the the
Prince of Chicago you know he's Chicago
royalty chance is one of my favorite
rappers and so I made this jacket it was
a three jacket his chances three I was
like okay I'll put this on Twitter we'll
see what this does like 30 seconds later
Chancellor ever his follow-through
chancellor efforts at you at DM i mean
he's like yo how do i get this and i was
like any way you want and he wore on the
cover of billboard and that was kind of
like how it started this it's for an
artist they make Jenkins
so hard I've made something like a
hundred and thirty-five pieces in the
last four years some of the people I've
made stuff for there's a Major Lazer
chance the rapper Mensa mos def Joey /
Kendrick Lamar oh yeah little yachty of
course how could I forget about lil
yachty but the majority of them are worn
by people who are not famous a lot of
people I make stuff for in Chicago where
there's stuff everyday living the things
cross-stitch is just a cross stitched
it's just a square you basically take an
image and you pixelate the hell out of
it
so you map out a bunch of tiny squares
it takes a very good spatial recognition
a lot of patience and you cannot mess it
up
my inspiration usually will come
complete finished everything from a
person it arrives in my head fully
formed and that's it I have no idea how
we get there I don't sit around and
think about it for somebody like the way
that I'm able to make something for
somebody as if it is there I have to go
out to the suburbs to buy my thread it's
all specialty I spend an ungodly amount
of money on thread it would freak you
out I always say like the median amount
of time and a jacket is anywhere from
like 50 to 60 hours when you're done
then you get to pull the graph out and
you could see what it looks like when
it's finished people call what's
happening in Chicago a Renaissance we
have art and we have music and we have
all these people making positive changes
all these people making incredible
incredible stuff I have a team that
oscillates anywhere from like 7 to 14
people and they're all artists they're
all other Chicago artists but we do
these big photo shoots with people who's
like really the only way that I can
along anything is by having pictures of
it the giving away part is the best part
to see something that you've made affect
somebody in what seems to be a
meaningful way is a pretty emotional
thing the goal with the Cross these
checkups is never to sell them or to
make money off of them it's truly truly
a passion project
I'm not Gucci I'm just you know I'm
stitch God
[Music]
[Music]